[Aplausos]
[Música]
durante los tres primeros meses del año
el precio del petróleo se ha desplomado
más de un 60 por ciento
si lo has escuchado bien más de un 60
por ciento
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea en el
momento de preparar este vídeo el precio
del crudo se encuentra al nivel del año
2002 y tal y como podéis sospechar en
todo esto ha tenido mucho que ver la
crisis desatada por el sars coronavirus
2 un virus que está convirtiendo buena
parte de las calles del mundo en una
especie de escenario de la película soy
leyenda de will smith
en este preciso momento en muchos países
del mundo están en marcha cuarentenas
obligatorias que están confinado a la
población en sus casas como es
precisamente el caso de españa donde
además como todos seguros ya sabéis
restaurantes bares hoteles comercios de
todo tipo muchas oficinas y fábricas
están cerradas y evidentemente todo esto
supone un duro golpe para la actividad
económica quereis algunos ejemplos
atentos
[Música]
el desempleo podría alcanzar el 30 por
ciento los eeuu según james bullard
presidente de la reserva federal de san
luis el impacto económico del
coronavirus será severo incluso tan malo
como la gran recesión según el fmi
volkswagen hierbas detienen la
producción europea en medio de una ola
de cierres de fábricas a medida que las
empresas cierran plantas los gobiernos
comienzan a desplegar ayuda financiera
para empresas y trabajadores
la cuestión es qué ocurre cuando la
economía se para de semejante forma pues
obviamente que la demanda de energía se
reduce y desde luego si hablamos de
energía y economía el crudo sigue siendo
el rey la sangre negra que discurre por
las venas de la economía mundial
de tal forma que si por ejemplo los
aviones apenas vuelan o el tráfico se
desploma porque la gente está confinada
en casa pues evidentemente el consumo de
petróleo se reduce y eso es exactamente
lo que está ocurriendo en su último
reporte correspondiente al mes de marzo
la agencia internacional de la energía
espera que la demanda de petróleo se
reduzca en 2020 por primera vez desde la
gran crisis financiera del 2008 solo
hace falta echar un vistazo a lo que ha
ocurrido en china para comprender qué
diantres está ocurriendo en el mercado
del petróleo durante el mes de febrero
mes en el que el gigante asiático
prácticamente paró su economía para
enfrentarse al sars coronavirus 2 su
demanda de petróleo se desplomó en más
de 3 millones de barriles diarios y como
ahora las medidas de prevención se están
extendiendo a lo largo y ancho de todo
el planeta el consumo de petróleo
también está cayendo en el resto del
mundo
y claro es un simple sistema de oferta y
demanda si la demanda cae y la oferta se
mantiene el precio se reduce ahora bien
un momento ya está esto es lo que
explica el castañazo que se ha pegado el
precio del petróleo pues amigos nada más
lejos de la realidad aquí empieza una
historia que tiene todos los atributos
necesarios para convertirse en un best
seller mundial rusia arabia saudita la
casa blanca y una pandemia mundial
habéis escuchado hablar de la nueva
guerra del petróleo atentos
[Música]
putin y la furia del mundo árabe
el día 6 de marzo de 2020 se celebró en
la capital de austria una importantísima
reunión
para los que no lo sepáis en viena se
encuentra la sede de la opep el poderoso
cartel del petróleo que aglutina a
muchos de los mayores productores de
crudo de todo el mundo una organización
que durante los últimos tres años ha
trabajado mano a mano con rusia para
fijar sus niveles de producción de
petróleo o mejor dicho para limitar la
extracción y evitar así que un exceso de
oferta hundiera los precios y era lo que
se conocía como la opep las
pues bien el caso es que ese día el 6 de
marzo la opep le propuso a rusia llevar
a cabo de forma conjunta un nuevo
recorte de la producción por un total de
un millón y medio de barriles para
tratar así de estabilizar el precio ante
el impacto del coronavirus
sin embargo amigos en esta ocasión rusia
de la mano de suministro de energía
alexander novak dijo no rechazó aceptar
nuevos recortes y rompió su alianza
petrolera con arabia saudita y ahí ahí
estalló todo
[Música]
la contestación no se hizo esperar los
audi tas tomaron la opción nuclear en
este caso inundar el mercado con mucho
muchísimo más petróleo y petróleo mucho
más barato
tras el fracaso del acuerdo con rusia
las autoridades sauditas anunciaron una
nueva estrategia incrementar un 25% su
producción de petróleo hasta niveles
nunca antes vistos 12 millones y medio
de barriles de petróleo al día y no
fueron los únicos poco tiempo después la
petrolera estatal de emiratos la abu
dhabi national company dijo también que
elevaría su producción hasta los 4
millones de barriles
quizá su parte rusia tampoco se quedó al
margen de esta especie de carrera y
anunció que podía incrementar su
producción en medio millón de barriles
más al día más oferta y menos demanda el
lunes 9 de marzo el precio del petróleo
sufrió una caída del 24% el mayor
desplome en un día en casi 30 años había
dado comienzo la nueva guerra del
petróleo
por supuesto toda esta carrera plantea
muchos dilemas un precio tan bajo puede
convertirse en todo un boquete en las
cuentas públicas de estos dos países y
de muchos otros la opep y la agencia
internacional de la energía advierten
que los países en vías de desarrollo
podrían perder hasta el 85 por ciento de
los ingresos del petróleo y el gas este
año países como nigeria angola ecuador o
méxico pueden pasarlo muy pero que muy
mal pero es que incluso para algunos
países del golfo pérsico todo este
asunto puede convertirse también en un
terrible dolor de cabeza
los gobiernos de más de una docena de
países productores de petróleo en áfrica
américa latina y países pobres en
oriente medio' no podrán pagar los
salarios de los empleados del gobierno
para mayo si los precios actuales
continúan hasta entonces a nasa alhaji
para que os hagáis una idea en omán el
déficit público puede dispararse por
encima del 20 por ciento del pib en
bahrein la deuda del gobierno va a
superar de largo el tamaño de toda la
economía nacional y en irak en irak
peligran incluso las nóminas de los
empleados públicos la mayor fuerza
laboral de todo el país
tampoco nos podemos olvidar del gran
imperio de los eeuu un país que durante
los últimos años se ha convertido en el
mayor productor de petróleo de todo el
mundo gracias a la técnica conocida como
fracking el problema sin embargo es que
sus productores suelen ser pequeños por
lo general están muy endeudados y sus
costes de extracción son mucho más altos
que el propio precio al que hoy por hoy
cotiza el crudo en otras palabras que
estos precios del petróleo podrían
llevarles a la quiebra y eso eso podría
suponer miles decenas de miles de
despidos y convertirse incluso en un
escollo para la reelección de donald
trump
pero amigos amigas llegados a este punto
las preguntas que podemos hacernos son
porque el reino saudí se ha lanzado a
semejante carrera porque demonio rusia
dijo que no a los recortes' cuánto
tiempo podrán resistir antes de que esta
nueva estrategia lleve al colapso las
cuentas públicas de estos dos países y
de otros muchos productores qué diantres
pasa con eeuu atentos
[Música]
rusia y la capacidad de resistir
amigos la economía rusa es básicamente
lo que se dice una economía exportadora
de materias primas aproximadamente la
mitad de todas las exportaciones rusas
son petróleo o productos derivados del
petróleo y junto al gas supone ni más ni
menos que el 40 por ciento de los
ingresos públicos pero un momento
entonces por qué diantres no aceptaron
los recortes propuestos por la opep para
estabilizar el precio del crudo en plena
crisis del color a virus porque
rompieron la baraja y se levantaron de
la mesa en qué demonios estaban pensando
[Música]
pues veréis por un lado no son pocos los
que defienden que todo este embrollo no
es más que una especie de partida de
póquer entre rusos y árabes
[Música]
de esta forma con su negativa a
disminuir su producción de petróleo el
gobierno de vladímir putin podría querer
forzar a que sean los propios árabes
quienes asuman todo el recorte de crudo
de tal forma que rusia podría seguir
vendiendo todos sus barriles a un precio
más alto
[Música]
sin embargo más allá de esa posibilidad
lo cierto es que los grandes gerifaltes
del petróleo ruso como es por ejemplo el
caso de rosneft la gran petrolera
pública de rusia llevan tiempo pidiendo
al crimen que suspenda sus acuerdos con
la opep porque pues porque consideran
que este tipo de acuerdos no tienen
ningún sentido para los intereses rusos
que por un lado recortar la producción
frena el desarrollo de nuevos campos
petrolíferos mientras que por otro
supone regalar cuota de mercado a la
industria del sail hoy de los eeuu
es decir para que nos entendamos que los
recortes de producción impulsados por la
opep estarían alimentando el renacer
petrolero del imperio norteamericano y
claro eso es algo que habla de putin
pues como que no oye que no le da la
gana pero la pregunta clave es puede el
gobierno ruso aguantar el suficiente
tiempo como para ahogar a la industria
de los eeuu y lograr que sean los árabes
quien asuman los recortes por cuenta
propia pues sí y no
[Música]
por un lado el gobierno ruso apenas
necesita poco más de 40 dólares por
barril para equilibrar su presupuesto
esto dista mucho de los más de 80
dólares que requiere el gobierno saudí
además durante los últimos años el
gobierno ruso ha acumulado cientos de
miles de millones en reservas
extranjeras que ahora podría utilizar
para resistir durante bastante tiempo
precios por debajo de los 30 dólares el
barril tiempo más que suficiente para
ahogar a las empresas de franklin de los
eeuu y para obligar a riad a tomar
medidas sin embargo por otro lado no es
menos cierto que la economía rusa no
crece que los ingresos de los hogares
son ahora más bajos que hace 8 años y
que ahora la caída de los ingresos
derivados del petróleo lo va a empeorar
todo
por ejemplo recordáis todos esos grandes
planes de nuevos equipos militares con
los que rusia nos bombardea una y otra y
otra vez pues al cajón esta amigos es la
posición rusa pero qué ocurre con arabia
saudita porque de repente pasaron de
querer recortar la producción a inundar
el mercado de crudo pues atentos
en el plan b de mohamed bin salman
[Música]
amigos no es la primera vez que arabia
saudita utiliza la 'guerra de precios'
para tratar de castigar a sus rivales el
problema es que hasta ahora este tipo de
estrategias siempre habían fracasado en
la década de los 80 utilizaron la guerra
de precios para intentar hundir a los
productores del mar del norte y hace
apenas unos pocos años en 2014
repitieron la jugada para tratar de
expulsar del mercado a las empresas de
franklin norteamericanas no lo lograron
para que os hagáis una idea de lo que
estamos hablando según datos de la
agencia internacional de la energía
esta estrategia le costó a los países de
la opep más de 450 mil millones de
dólares en tan sólo los dos años que
estuvo en vigor 450.000 millones pero
ahora bien un momento lo cierto es que
últimamente algunas cosas han cambiado
[Música]
veréis me explico arabia saudi no es
sólo uno de los mayores productores de
crudo del mundo sino también uno de los
mayores consumidores concretamente el
quinto mayor consumidor de oro negro de
todo el planeta parece una locura pero
cada año arabia saudi consume más
petróleo de países como alemania o reino
unido de hecho aunque parezca difícil de
creer consume casi tanto petróleo como
japón
[Música]
precisamente por este motivo durante los
últimos años el gobierno saudí ha puesto
sobre la mesa algunas medidas para
reducir su consumo y liberar así más
petróleo para exportar por ejemplo están
invirtiendo muchísimos recursos para
duplicar en pocos años su producción de
gas natural y sustituir completamente al
petróleo la producción de electricidad
también están reduciendo los subsidios a
la gasolina y poniendo en marcha un
montón de planes de eficiencia
energética de esta forma entre el
incremento de la producción y el menor
consumo local
el gobierno saudí confía en tener la
capacidad de incrementar más de un 40%
sus exportaciones de crudo
[Música]
y amigos esto es precisamente lo que
podría permitirles a los sauditas poner
en marcha lo que se conoce como una
estrategia de monetización rápida es
decir aprovechar su ventaja en costes
recordad que ya os hemos contado muchas
veces aquí en visual polític que arabia
saudita a tienen los menores costes de
extracción del mundo para incrementar su
cuota de mercado y expulsar a muchos de
sus competidores de esta forma la mayor
cuota de mercado no sólo podría
compensar con creces los precios más
bajos logrando incrementar los ingresos
del reino saudí sino que estos precios
más bajos contribuirían a ralentizar la
llegada de tecnologías como el coche
eléctrico es algo que en riad llevan
barajando desde hace años y que ahora el
golpe en la mesa de rusia podría
haberles lanzado a este cambio de
estrategia
[Música]
claro que todo esto funciona en la
teoría en la práctica del problema es
que a corto plazo las cuentas públicas
pueden sufrir mucho los recursos para
llevar a cabo su plan de diversificación
visión 2030 podrían quedar en nada y ni
siquiera está claro que los nuevos
competidores desaparecerían por completo
y amigos
podéis creerme no hay nada que asusté
más a un árabe que ver como sus inmensas
reservas de dinero se desploman año tras
año
por eso lo cierto es que todo apunta a
que si hubiera acuerdo los saudíes
estarían mucho pero que mucho más
cómodos siguiendo como hasta ahora claro
que si no es posible este es el plan y
eso eso nos lleva directamente hasta los
eeuu contra las cuerdas
durante los últimos años los eeuu han
visto renacer su industria del petróleo
hasta el punto de convertirse de nuevo
en el mayor productor mundial de oro
negro todo gracias al fracking
[Música]
el problema el problema es que los
costes de extracción de las empresas de
franklin son mucho muchísimo más altos
que el coste de extracción de países
como arabia saudita
hablamos de una diferencia que puede
llegar a ser en algunos casos de casi 40
dólares el barril
y claro con precios en el entorno de 25
pues las cuentas no salen y eso es lo
que explica noticias como estas billete
de los perforadores más importantes de
texas recortan siete mil seiscientos
millones de dólares sus presupuestos de
inversión a medida que los precios del
petróleo colapsan y esto esto es sólo el
comienzo y claro la industria del
petróleo se ha convertido en uno de los
motores de la economía norteamericana
disney gualeguay
de hecho durante los últimos años ha
sido responsable de la creación de
decenas y decenas de miles de empleos y
también de al menos el 10 por ciento de
todo el crecimiento económico y ahora
por culpa de esta guerra gran parte de
toda esa inmensa riqueza está en peligro
y con ella la propia reelección del
presidente trampa la situación es tan
seria que la casa blanca baraja incluso
dos escenarios que hasta hace pocas
semanas hubieran resultado del todo
impensables por un lado a amenazar con
imponer aranceles al petróleo
procedentes de arabia saudí y de otros
países de la opep para igualar su precio
de venta al que necesitan los
productores locales por otro lado según
ha publicado el wall street journal el
departamento de estado ha planteado la
posibilidad de presionar a arabia
saudita para que se retire de la opep y
alcance un acuerdo total con los eeuu en
ese caso estaríamos hablando de una
alianza prácticamente total entre los
dos países una alianza más fuerte que el
vínculo entre eeuu e israel
en esta tertulia con de 20 mil el valor
de este estratégico
en fin amigos esta es la nueva guerra
del petróleo que han desatado la crisis
del corah virus una guerra que nos deja
muchas preguntas terminarán poniéndose
de acuerdo rusia y arabia saudita para
que las aguas vuelvan a su cauce
estaremos viendo el inicio de una nueva
era en el mundo de la energía cuánto
tiempo podrá resistir arabia saudita a
unos precios del petróleo tan bajos a
ellos dejamos las preguntas vuestras son
las respuestas podéis compartirlas con
todos nosotros en la sección de
comentarios y por cierto si queréis
conocer más sobre el impacto económico
que está teniendo el coronavirus no os
perdáis este vídeo que ha preparado
alberto junto a nuestros amigos de valió
school en fin una vez más muchas gracias
por estar ahí un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]